(Monika laughs)
- [Mark] You're very fun to look at.
- (laughs) Thank you.
- [Mark] And we go again.
- [Monika] So I'll just say everything
and you could cut out
anything that you don't want.
I'll just be as authentic.
- [Mark] Yeah.
I just think it would
be good to have a talk
about helping people, because
it's not as simple as like
I think a lot of people see my videos and
they see Caroline who we just spoke to,
or we see...
Oh, it's an endless list of
people that come in here.
"Oh my God, they just need
this, that and the other...
"Don't you help them?"
And I'm sure
we could probably shed a little light on
what helping these
people is actually like.
- Sure.
- [Mark] 'Cause that's what you do, right?
- Yeah.
So, I mean, since the first video,
you and I have tried to
help a number of people.
I always try to basically
have interface with someone.
So if Mark or anyone else says to me,
"I have someone who really needs support."
I want to sit down with them
and I want to hear from them directly.
I prefer if they're not high,
but I understand sometimes
that's unavoidable,
especially when it comes
to things like crack
'cause then it's really challenging.
Because crack does so much to your psyche.
- [Mark] Crack is harder
to deal with heroin or--
- In my experience.
I'm not a doctor, but in my experience
because of like this...
Psychosis may not be the correct term,
but because of what happens to someone
when they're high on crack,
the visions, the voices,
it's really challenging to even
get to the core of a person
- [Mark] I mean, they're
all terrible drugs.
And they're all...
- They're all awful.
But in terms of interfacing
to find out if someone
is ready for treatment
and if they really want this,
it's more challenging with meth and crack
than it is some of the other drugs.
For me anyway, maybe that's...
I don't know why would that would be
but that's how it's been
because I can't get to a person.
So, since the first video
you've brought a number of people to me.
If they show up for the
meeting, like we just had one
and they left in the middle of it
because they were
hallucinating or...
- [Mark] What did she say?
"No, I think I'm good."
And then she just--
- Yeah, we were in the
middle of talking about
what treatment looks like
and what her dreams
would be moving forward.
And she just said, "I'm good" and left.
- No, and just to add,
there have been more than a couple people
that I've tried to help in a serious way.
Like, cause what you're
offering is basically housing,
an education, job
training, therapy, rehab,
the whole thing on a silver platter,
all you gotta do is show up.
And we've had a couple people there,
a couple of teenage people
that everyone was screaming at.
"Oh my God, why don't
you help these people?"
So we lined it all up with you,
with your organization Patrick Cady.
And
I don't want to name names
but if you've watched my channel
you'll figure out who I'm talking about.
So we arranged an appointment
for that person to show up
with you and me and
we're gonna lay it all out for
how we're gonna save your life.
We don't say it that way.
We just like, "Would you like rehab?
"Would you like housing?
"Would you like an education?
"Would you like some job training?
"Would you like some therapy?"
They say "Yes"
and they fail to show
up for the appointment.
And then we give them a second chance.
- Yes. Always.
- [Mark] And again, they fail to show up.
So ultimately it becomes more about,
getting them to accept,
being fulfilled and happy in life,
which is the biggest hurdle.
- It's really challenging
and I don't fault the
people that don't show up
and I don't have any
frustration toward them.
I just think it's
important to give context.
And that context is,
these people have gone their
entire lives most of them,
being abused and being
told that they are nothing.
So even if they are
presented with an opportunity
that you want to give them
or that Patrick Cady wants to give them,
or is it Aurora?
- [Mark] Aura.
- Aura.
Or that Aura wants to give them.
It seems so unreal,
that I think it just it's
like some sort of fantasy
alternate reality to where they are
and they deserve the help but,
the mental health aspect is what we don't
really have a grasp on.
And what brings someone to
the streets a lot of time
and what brings someone to drugs is
where they're at mentally
and the abuse and the
mistreatment that's taken place.
So it's like, you think,
"Oh, well, here's this opportunity
"that people would just
be running and lining up."
But that doesn't even align
with what brings someone
to be in this place in the first place.
If things were that easy,
they wouldn't be here.
- [Mark] Yeah, as I said, I
think in the last Norman video.
It's not about drugs.
Drugs are not the issue.
Drugs are just a symptom
of the much, much deeper
and more stubborn problem of,
loving yourself and being
able to accept a better
life for yourself.
Which they can't.
And how do you fix somebody's childhood?
I don't even know.
- It's like even the people
that I do get through to
that we do work with,
even after they've been
sober for a year or two,
it doesn't go away.
And if anything, it gets louder.
So kind of like I talked about before,
it's such a large hurdle
and it's so unbelievable to most people
that someone would come in out of nowhere
and make us a real effort to just,
give them more opportunity
when they've been taught
over and over for decades
that they don't deserve
those opportunities.
So it's just, I mean, even
when we posted the last video
I got a number of inquiries
through Patrick Cady Foundation website.
And I didn't get a single person
that actually followed up with me.
I emailed everybody back.
I said, "Set a time to
have a call with me.
"Let's discuss whether it be them
"or their child or whatever."
I did have one mom that did respond to me,
that was saying, that explained
her daughter's situation.
And I said, "Okay, I just
need your daughter to call me
"because I'm not gonna get
somebody through treatment
"if I can't talk to them first."
There's no world where
I can even be of support
or anyone else in our
foundation can do anything,
if the person isn't willing
to have a conversation.
Her daughter never called me.
And it's not anyone's fault.
But it's so deeply ingrained
in people that end up in these situations.
And again, it's such a large hurdle
and we have to have such patience.
Like for what you do,
I see you give money
to people all the time.
It takes such patience to not
get frustrated or lose hope
because all that we
want at the foundation,
all that I want as a human being
is to take care of other
people and help other people.
And when nobody will show up and meet me
or if they meet me and they walk out,
it's like, "Oh, shit."
Like how do I help?
And I think that that's what
you're doing here is awareness.
Awareness is how we help
because it's a concerted effort.
- [Mark] I mean, I do more
than my share of helping.
- You do, a lot (laughs).
- [Mark] And I try not to show that
because I don't want this
to be a help channel.
This channel I'm doing is not about,
"Oh, let's help this person.
"Let's help Caroline.
"Let's help whoever,
you name your person."
It's about creating awareness
so that we can prevent this
'cause I see that as the real solution.
'Cause I don't think we
can patch all these people.
- No.
- [Mark] There are
thousands of people here
just on Skid Row.
And there are other communities like this
all across the country.
And in every viewer's
hometown I guarantee you,
there are people just like this.
So you don't need to like
travel across the country
and fix Caroline.
If you want to help these people,
figure out somebody right in
your backyard, that's doing it,
doing the same damage to themselves.
But the purpose of this channel
is not about helping Caroline.
The purpose of this
channel is to show you how,
keeping families intact and together
and supporting communities that are rich.
Just churning over
generation after generation,
after generation of these
uneducated, damaged people
from broken families.
That's gonna be the solution
'cause I don't think we
can fix Caroline or...
I mean, a lot of these
people that we're gonna...
Let's say we did help.
Let's say we got them rehab.
We got them an education.
We got them some job training.
We got them some therapy.
They still have a long,
long list of problems,
like the inability to trust others.
The inability to create trust from others.
The inability to handle money.
They see money, they burn it.
It's what they do.
They don't understand saving money.
- They don't know any better,
'cause they doesn't know.
No one's taught them to save money.
- [Mark] They don't understand
postponed gratification.
They don't understand
anything you need to do to
fulfill your (mumbles), be
functional and have a happy life.
That's why I think
prevention is the answer.
And that's the purpose of this channel.
It's not about fixing these
people 'cause I don't know,
that you, me and 150,000 other people
could actually help
Caroline.
Or who just walked out of here.
It's such a big problem.
And it's so difficult to help
each and every one of these people.
The purpose, again, I'm saying
it for the 400th time is
let's see what's broken about our society
so this doesn't happen.
'Cause it's gonna happen again and again,
and it's gonna grow and
it's already growing,
look around your town.
- Right. I know.
Ever since COVID downtown in Skid Row is,
just grown exponentially.
- [Mark] Without even about COVID.
COVID is a whole nother
problem that makes it worse.
But--
- But it's just growing and growing--
- [Mark] This was growing rapidly
for the last 10, 20 years.
And I'm sure it's gonna continue
unless we do some things to
address what's causing it.
- And for us as a nonprofit,
we do intend to help.
But it's just important
that people understand
what help really looks like
and who is actually willing
to receive that help because
it's proven to be
exceptionally challenging
to find people that even want the help.
- [Mark] That's right.
That's it right there.
Nobody really...
They say they want it on video.
I mean, there's been a
couple of people that
sat where you're sitting and said,
"I just wish somebody would help me."
And your eyes start watering
and your heart opens up
and you want to help them.
And when the rubber hits the road
they actually don't want the help.
They can't accept it.
And the answer is not to,
"Oh, just well, screw them
and forget about them."
Because I believe, I'm not religious
but I believe you need to be like Jesus
and just keep giving 'em a chance,
keep giving 'em a chance,
even when they screw up for the 15th time,
you keep giving them a chance.
- That's patience. We have to have that.
- [Mark] That's what you need.
And it requires so much.
And I can't do it for all
of the 2000 people plus
that I've interviewed.
And there's 12,000 more
that I haven't interviewed.
They're all surrounding me here.
It's just too much for one person.
And if you guys all want to fly out to LA
and fix everybody on
Skid Row, come on out.
But there's people in your hometown,
in New Jersey or Philadelphia
or Miami or Chicago,
wherever, that are in
the same exact situation.
So you don't need to come here.
This is not just an odd
situation that happens in LA.
This is happening all across the country
and probably all over the world.
- Yeah. It really is.
And it really just boils down to awareness
and the willingness to be patient
and the willingness to understand
the human condition enough
to love these people outside of
what you're seeing on
your YouTube channel.
You know what I'm saying?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Somebody taught them that
that's what they were worth.
So again, it goes back to how
we're treating these children
how we're keeping these families,
what we're doing systemically
to support people who need support.
That's where we actually break this cycle.
And as far as the people
who were already here
we'll do everything we can.
But it's hard.
- [Mark] Yeah. I had
lunch with you a month ago
and you said one of the
most interesting things
I've ever heard,
which I can't stop thinking about,
which is,
it's a recycling
multi-generational problem.
Every family keeps doing
the same thing to their own
and it just goes on and on.
And I go, "When did this start?
"Did it get worse?"
And you said,
"No, this is how the country was built."
I'm paraphrasing.
But you said something like,
"This is how the United
States was created.
"A bunch of Europeans came here,
"raped and stole from the Indians.
"And that generation did
it to the following gen...
"It just continued on.
"And it looks different
"every a hundred years,
it looks different.
"So now it's about homelessness and drugs
"and all that kind of stuff.
"But a hundred years ago, it
was, it looked very different
"but it was all the same problem."
- It was all the same problem
and things were just more separate.
- [Mark] Yeah, 'cause this
what the country was built on.
- With the internet and everything else,
we're getting exposed to
things that have been existing
for the entirety of
this country's history.
But before it was hidden
away in the projects
or wherever it was and other people,
people like us that are
privileged didn't see it.
But it is we...
This country started out
with a violent intent.
- [Mark] It was built on violence.
- It was built on violence.
So to unlearn that,
we have to figure out
how to have more of a sense of community.
And that comes in at all angles,
not everybody should be helping.
Not everybody should be doing something.
We just have to figure this out.
And like you said, be like Jesus
and have some patience and
understanding for people.
- [Mark] Yeah.
It's a huge problem.
It's growing.
And patching the broken
ones is not the answer.
That's a simplistic attitude.
I think you have to think much bigger,
which is the purpose of my channel,
is let's look at what's
wrong, what's broken,
so that we can start
figuring out how to solve it.
'Cause I don't even know if,
doing things to keep families
together would it even work
or be the total solution
'cause then there's still the lack of hope
in these communities.
The lack of
like...
- It runs so deep and it's
so complicated and systemic
that it seems
impossible at times.
But if we all start to have
the same conversations,
it becomes more and more possible.
- [Mark] Exactly.
I think
you can say it's about the family.
You can say it's about
the lack of education
or the lack of opportunities in
some of the communities
that these people grow in,
grow up into.
But
ultimately I hate to
be one of these people
but it's ultimately about love.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And if (mumbles)
ever wants their name back,
I would change the name
to Unconditional Love.
Cause that's really what it's all about.
- That's what we're missing.
We're divided by politics
or divided by race.
We're divided by all these things that,
aren't doing us any good.
We have to learn how to fall
back in love with ourselves
and with each other and with the community
that we're a part of
because we have to take
care of this world,
we only get one
and that's it.
So you and I will keep doing our part
and everybody can do something
no matter how small it is
buy the person behind you
when you're at Walmart,
buy their stuff.
If it's a mom with three kids
and you can tell she's
struggling and you're okay
just buy it, just do something
to give other people help.
- [Mark] Beautifully said.
Monika, you're amazing.
- Thank you (laughs).
- [Mark] Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] This was just an impromptu thing.
We were trying to meet Caroline
to help her get on in
one of your programs,
and she turned on her heels and ran away.
- And it's okay.
Because if she decides she wants it again,
I'll meet with her again.
- Yeah, no, I love Carolina.
She's the greatest.
She's my original, like,
the first friend I
really made down here and
I've known her for 10 or 11 years and
it hurts.
It breaks my heart every
time I see her out there
trying to pick up some
guy who's just gonna...
- [Monika] Yeah.
That's hard.
- [Mark] Give her 30
bucks for some crazy act
that she's gonna do and--
- [Monika] I know.
- [Mark] And it's just so sad that
you're doing your part--
- [Monika] We're gonna keep going.
- [Mark] Yeah, you're amazing.
Thank you so much.